this abandoned Napoleonic fort stands
guard over the Thames Estuary London's
River gateway there is a unique place
Simon Cooper's owned the fort since 2002
go then he bought it off the crown
estate but won't say for how much so
lovely place to be now he's selling it I
come across it whilst the exploring one
day and the tide went out while we was
here and exposed the Bulls way so we
went and explored he would have liked to
make it into a house but the costs are
too high gods that's where London
high-end real estate agent Nigel day
comes in co and the owner Simon told
came into office and said he's got a a
grain tower thought they was thinking of
selling again I wasn't too interested
but then he said the address is number
one the tens couch at just have a look
inside you look at the brickworks not be
you know a ring down the incitement are
showing some potential buyers around
their casino owners from Belgium one of
a list of international buyers lining up
to see the mid 19th century fort I've
been an estate agent for 3 15 years now
I've never known anything that's come
anywhere near getting this sort of
coverage interest excitements it's just
phenomenal willing buyers have been
talking about turning it into anything
from a hotel to a mansion to a houseboat
center so yeah you get a quite a good
view of their oft-returning placement
it's even a group using crowdfunding to
raise money to transform it into a
nightclub but there's no more time for
daydreaming another 10 minutes and the
tide will be out earlier we're gonna
have to be going home Sony there's a
course we can port estoy 4i hours i
think is
it's not easy getting back to shore the
next owner might not have to trample
through the mud one potential buyer has
discussed putting in a helipad simon
says he's sorry to see it go like the
fort's been his personal playground for
over 10 years soon it will be someone
else's Angus Bennett Bloomberg the
Thames Estuary